[Musique]
c'est bon mais où et série vidéo hockey
et ben vas tu écoutes d'équidés que vous
êtes en direct vous me le dites
donc c'est sérieux
t'es sérieux là l'envié
bonsoir à tous vous êtes cuisine général
hu à londres ou alors que française
principalement françaises
d'accord mais vous ne faisiez ou sans
citer de marque injuste dans ce genre de
restaurant un ehpad dans un ehpad très
bien et donc un jour vous l'écuyer de la
véritable nourriture ou vous là pour
l'instant vous
ils vont être contents vous entend
continuer merci pour le
professionnalisme de cyril lignac qui a
failli me laisser tout seul je te ferais
la même chose un soir à l'olympia cyril
j'arrive tout cela dépêche-toi cours
pensée positive perpétuel et 3p c'est ma
devise
je suis d'accord positive et les trois
mois je connais les 3,6 mais choqué oui
alors ne rentrera pas dans les détails
et 3,6 à sallaumines l'iace va recevoir
de nouvelles toilettes
oui j'assume complètement cette
chronique c'est probablement les
toilettes les plus chers que vous n'avez
jamais vu 23 millions de dollars
c'est environ 20 millions d'euros voilà
à quoi ça ressemble c'est très
impressionnant et comme dispositif
dessert ou jeter ses deux copines
s'éclate dans la gadoue proust ou c'est
qui déjà
c'est un prénom c'est quoi tous ces
personnes juste un des plus grands
écrivains romanesque français du xxème
siècle sousse centre est pensé trop
taper la question des toilettes c'est
une question qui est aussi vieille que
la première mission spatiale les
astronautes s'en plaigne très souvent
cette fois ci la nasa me paquet le
modèle est plus compact plus léger plus
confortable aussi parce qu'il y à un
siège alors si le numéro deux alors la
feuille qui dedans elle n'est pas
comestible hein c'est juste moi des
cours ouais elle a été lavé avant non
puis je me suis dit gérer l'uriné
recyclée directement sur la station en
eau potable
c'est à dire que le café d'aujourd'hui
est aussi celui de demain pour les
matières disons solides elles sont dans
un premier temps stocker à bord d'un
vaisseau de maintenance puis bouillis
lors du passage du vaisseau dans
l'atmosphère une partie et réacheminés
sur terre pour analyse
il ne me reste plus qu'à vous souhaiter
monty déjà alors c'est pas très glamour
on est au petit déjeuner c'est pas très
sympa de ma part mais je trouve que
c'est quand même
irréel sauf que c'est du colorant
alimentaire donc malheureusement c'est
pas la vraie couleur et servir chloé
pour être un peu plus blanc des tampons
pesticides ou autres entrants m'a vu je
ne mérite pas ce traitement lac
c'est tellement bien
de culotte menstrues coton bio
on va juin
leblanc ça tu as super bien tu veux
penser à marine landrot là là tout de
suite la récitation la récitation de
marilyn monroe
bien bien bien et j'ai rencontré
quelqu'un dans ma vie qui a touché mon
coeur est cette personne là c'est jésus
christ ouais ouais c'est sûr alors je
souhaiterais des chrétiens ici des
musulmans voilà des voilà vraiment des
personnes qui ont la foi
moi j'ai la foi j'ai l'espérance et je
sais que le christ te revient c'est
vraiment un message d'amour déjà je vous
bénis tout ce je vous aime tous sachez
que dieu vous aime jésus vous aime et il
a donné sa vie à la croix pour vous tous
pour vous sauver de vos péchés moi qui
suis à la ligue des droits de l'animal
je me dis mais est ce qu'il faudrait pas
faire passer les droits de l'animal
avant les droits de l'homme vu le mal
qu'on a avec les droits de l'homme si on
arrivait à faire passer les droits de
l'animal tête après ce serait plus
facile des cirques sans animaux sauvages
impensable pour la famille muller qui ne
décolère pas contre la ministre
on a les 306 reprend en a on a eu tout
le monde au téléphone on est prêt à
monter avec tous les animaux à paris et
envahi faire un beau cadeau à madame la
mise
vous les voulez les animaux tiens c'est
pas sur un délai de cinq ans on va vous
imposez arrivée coup les semis vous
mettre les animaux dans paris bontemps
ton quand même de trouver des motifs de
réjouissance mais enfin il faut quand
même être assez honnête il ne reste pas
grand chose c'est à dire le goût
heureusement grand motif de réjouissance
et de bonheur bien sûr mais la réalité
c'est que bientôt il ne restera plus que
ça c'est à dire le même os x line le
boulot oui l'amour à moi c'est
merveilleux ça c'est quand on a besoin
un peu d'amitié de voir des gens
on allait faire la fête c'est la france
quoi d'aller boire un verre on a tous
envie de revivre comme on vivait avant
on a tous marre de porter le masque
quand on est obligés de le porter on a
tous marre de ne pas pouvoir faire la
bise ses amis ne pas pouvoir prendre
dans les bras ce qu'on aime c'est
pénible et on a tous envie de même en
gpo être au gouvernement j'ai 31 ans je
me dois faire la fête on a tous envie de
ça quand de dos nous fait des grandes
leçons je trouve ça débile
oui enfin je trouve ça idiot parce que
c'est une position d'enfant gâté
idéologique et moi j'ai travaillé à la
croix rouge va faire le mariole à
l'hôpital dans les services d'urgences
là où il ya des urgences tisci rice leur
coup en première ligne tous les jours
pour sauver des vies qui m'ulcère c'est
l'intolérance ce qui m'ulcère c'est
finalement le rôle des artistes c'est de
prouver que la vie existe c'est de
prouver que finalement on peut douter
non j'imagine que la juste réponse elle
est un équilibre entre
sauver le sauver les emplois sauver les
vies et sauver des vies dans les deux
sens mais il ya un mois j'ai pas
l'intelligence suffisante pour vous dire
ce qu'il faut faire
parfois j'ai l'impression que vous
mitraillé mitraillé mitraille locaux
vides aux infos et demi de vous
délaissez certains sujets en fait je
pense que là on est à l'aube d'un une
nouvelle époque d'un nouveau jour c'est
l'occasion pour nous de créer un nouveau
monde
un truc trop stylé où on est plus tous
un peu des connards voilà c'était moi le
plus d'adjectifs qualificatif possible
chacun breton grecque
[Musique]
non adjectif qualificatif qui qualifie
quelqu'un greg mais maman je vais m'y
mettre et je vais me mettre à la cuisine
puisqu'en ce moment je peux pas jouer au
théâtre je peux pas faire de tournée je
peux rien faire je vais mettre que ce
qu'on pense tu pourrais préféré à
travailler puisque tu joues être
améliorée puisque tu joues plus du beau
linge à travailler mais travailler ou
voilà c'est bien ma toile va être vendue
pour une oeuvre charitable de carrie
tivité c'est génial une femme
charitables je fais la charité mais
attend est ce que je rêve où ma mère
après 30 ans de carrière
la de seine et 30 longs métrages et une
tournée dans le monde entier elle m'a
dit trouve toi un emploi